but we have this article about ben
shapiro that i'm just you know honestly
okay
we're not going to talk about
entrepreneur i heard he bought a bunch
of what that was that was the big story
that was today's news cycle
here i was making cartoons about maxine
waters when what i really should have
been paying attention to was who's going
to home depot ben shapiro okay folks i'm
at home depot right now i'm gonna buy
this i'm gonna buy this two by four and
i'm just gonna
just gonna beat a small child with it
mercilessly mercilessly
we had this whole conversation before
the show that was very hilarious
we were laughing nonstop for like 20
minutes before the show joking about
like why ben shapiro went to home depot
to buy wood and why he was like showing
it off
and he's like okay he was beating
children was i think that was you i
don't remember which one of us because
franklin
well i i said mercilessly but you were
the one that brought it up
i was the one with two hours of sleep
tim you don't have an excuse
no it's like okay honestly here's why i
support home depot okay because they
still have child
they still allow child labor which is
american and it's it's part of the free
market and
you are able to test their wood boards
to see how strong they are by just
hitting children with it and so you just
like one of them's gonna break the two
by four the child and
it's important to know if you have two
by four strong enough to to actually uh
beat a child mercilessly with it all
right king i mean that's the news right
the story this is from forbes they say
that uh
ben shapiro took time out of his data
shop at home depot in pursuit of an
abstract culture war victory that
resulted in yet another dose of internet
humiliation
i gotta be honest no i saw the clip and
it's been holding a bag
with like a plank like a 1x6 plank in it
or like something
and he's like that is a great piece of
wood my friends i thought it was a joke
like i thought it was satire i was like
oh he's being silly he's doing a bit
maybe he's but then someone posted
another video where he was like i'm here
at home depot and i'm going to buy stuff
and i was like wait is he seriously
advocating like
yeah but like it's a joke if you bought
a 2x4 and then made a bit about it
it's not so much a joke i guess if
you're literally documenting your
experience going to home depot and
advocating for people to go there see i
don't know see i would do that as a
troll i'd be like
let's see what the internet gets upset
about i bet they'll get super wound
about me literally going to a store and
buying a piece of wood let's see if we
can make it happen yeah i mean
here's the thing you can definitely say
it's silly but i mean it's good to
support a business that promotes your
values
too so much of so many corporate
entities
are bending the knee right now so why
not support the ones who don't and i
think
here's the thing i think home depot
understands that they can't like how
many home depot customers are woke dude
oh no home depot wants you to come shop
at their place when you have to rebuild
their store because you got looted
i know right let me let's pull the
street from michael knowles michael
nolan's tweet
ben shapiro bought a plank of what is
nationally trending news
all right i i got to stop i got to stop
what's that shapiro masterfully played
yep yeah masterfully it was it was
trending on twitter
it was trending and dude ben shapiro
knows how to get pressed
yes he does he's like you know you know
what i think happened or does he just
get pressed because he's been shapiro
maybe but listen he's sitting i imagine
they're all sitting at the daily wire
office
and they're like what do we do and ben's
like i bet i could literally just like
buy a plank of wood i bet my gang and it
would be like national news it's gonna
be so big it is we're gonna we're gonna
troll the libs it's gonna be so epic
i'm gonna beat a child with a two by
four we're gonna go to the home parking
lot let me read this
i gotta hear it politics trending ben
shapiro shares a video of himself
purchasing a single wood blanket home
depot
after a coalition of black faith leaders
in georgia called for a boycott of the
company
over its unwillingness to condemn the
state's new voting law
that is the stupidest thing i have ever
read in every respect
that is amazing but i will tell you
listen there there are all these
companies where like all the ceos were
like we condemn georgia's
voting law and home depot was like i
don't know so they were like we condemn
home depot
that's dumb ben shapiro mocking them by
making a silly video
is like it's a hilarious troll by the
way i don't know if you guys
noticed but the top reply to michael
knowles tweet is from an account called
freedom tunes which you
which you should all check out
okay gang this is epic all right i got
my two by far we're gonna go own some
lives of this we're gonna own some lips
at the two by four which
by which i mean we're just gonna go
we're just gonna go beat antifa with my
two by four all right this is really
high quality lumber
folks i am less than 2 000 subs away
from
600k if you want to run over to freedom
tunes
mash that subscribe button check out the
three cartoons we made this week i love
all of you
back to our ben shapiro
gizmodo ben shapiro finally manages to
get wood
shot yeah but they're writing an article
about him
you know what i was i noticed something
didn't jimmy kimmel make fun of tucker
crosston recently
uh yeah jimmy jimmy kimmel did like a
bit making fun of tucker carlson
and then uh david pakman also did a bit
where he said that tucker crosstalk has
a psychotic break on his show
yeah i realized something they are
they're having withdrawals from trump
yeah yes 100 dude they've been having
withdrawals for a while
they had that tds turned out it was
actually just an addiction yeah
cult worship these people are are
possible i love trump so much and now
that he's gone
it's like you know donald trump was that
what was it breaking bad that that blue
meth that was trump it was this pure
it was amazing they were just like ah
and now they're like now they're now
they're pulling off
like a hunter biden digging through the
carpet yeah for
parmesan cheese thinking it's crack when
you when you when you go from like
the most corrupt president in history is
incited to insurrection
and you think you're like writing great
works for the annals of history
and then you're like meant to be
robotwood
carlson left ben shapiro buying a piece
of wood
is the hunter biden smoking parmesan
cheese of news
that's that's that's that's it i said it
that's it wow i can't believe you just
went there tim
i i'm like it's the it's the cult dude
this cult worship i mean it's been
around
since the dawn of humanity people are
obsessed with with people
i haven't i've reached the conclusion
that we get the journalism that we
deserve
100 100 think this is a manifestation
punishment for our sins
can i un-ironically yes like there's a
reason god's not sparing us from this
that's all
i i actually mean that i actually mean
can i just say though like
watching the 80 million story about how
trump did something he didn't do
was like infuriating watching them
basically like rocking back and forth
with like
dark rings around their eyes digging
through digging through the carpet for
parmesan parmesan
hilarious yeah this story about benjamin
i'm just sitting there i'm like i'm here
for a man cause you know we're not
struggling on this show
we're not we're not struggling for news
or topics to talk about we have a good
time
we'll talk about movies we got you know
we got some uh justice league stuff we
can talk about
these people are in panic mode yeah like
when they needed him they needed him he
complete remember in the dark night we
were just watching the dark knight
when the joker's like i can't kill you
you're too much fun like
he's like expressing to batman that he
wants to keep him like you complete me
that's exactly how they are with trump
except maybe trump's the joker you know
because we live in a society and he
knows it no trump's not the joker
i don't think it's trump batman he's
harvey dent dude these are pizzas
actually two-faced yeah maybe
i mean harvey dent was a suit wearing
blonde dude in the movie closer to trump
than anything yeah
and and actually i wouldn't say it's
like a perfect but if i had to say which
character he was it'd be harvey dent
in that he's a man of the law but he
takes things a little too far
you know what i mean then who is batman
is the question who is batman
it couldn't be bernie sanders he's
joking joe biden
yes 100 joe biden's the joker doesn't
make any sense
the media is the joker you think so the
media was the joker yeah because he's
just too much fun he can't kill him like
the joker was trying to
make crazy things happen because it was
fun and he was trying to shake things up
and hold on what did the joker say to
harvey dent in the hospital
if i tell the press that like a gang
banger will get shot or a truckload of
soldiers will be blowing up bits nobody
cares it's all according to planned
parenthood of the plan but if i say one
little old mayor's gonna die well then
everyone loses their minds
people love to plan even if it's
terrible horrifying
that doesn't sound like that that sounds
like that sounds more like antifa
the little bit sounds like we're living
in a society i have to stop that's such
a tired joke what's wrong with society
i love it but we get the media we
deserve man
we 100 too yeah we brought this upon
ourselves we're still consuming this
stuff
i thought that eleanor roosevelt she
just said that great minds think about
ideas
uh i don't know mediocre minds talk
about things and then like weak minds
talk about people and why are you
talking about eleanor roosevelt ian
you brought i fell for it
in that there are a lot of people who
make youtube careers off of talking
about drama
and i'm like does anyone really care
about
like when you know sometimes i'll talk
about things that are relevant to me
personally yeah i try to avoid that
and i'm like do people tune into the
show to hear about my petty drama
no they don't i would personally i'm
just saying i would if we just did tim's
drama cast
and you're like talking about everything
in your life somebody threw my beanie on
the ground
that wasn't oh i was i was kicking
things over he totally was
ah i'm kidding but but you know i think
about all these people try to drag
drag me or other people in drama and i'm
like let me tell you why one of the
reasons i think
the work i do is is more successful than
many other people on youtube
doing it for longer is that many people
on youtube who are in this commentary
space
would single out individuals no one
really cares about to make drama because
drama content was it was easy clicks
but extrapolate that to the mainstream
media instead of telling us about
jake they tell us about trump well i
mean listen the jake paul fighting
uh that was actually a thing yeah he's
gonna fight mayweather right i think so
that's going to be the fastest boxing
match i've ever seen yeah dude jake
paul's going to take him out dude real
quick one hitter quitter man
dude i can see it it's brilliant it's
it's brilliant but
i think that's that i think that's
culturally relevant like yeah one of the
best boxers ever and some crazy guy on
youtube
he's going to fight him i want to watch
that that's i think
that's that's good to talk about because
it's it's a it's the best boxer you know
what i mean it's like he's like
the main guy and we're getting this i
wouldn't say it's the most important
thing in the world but something to talk
about i would say it is
but when you have nothing imagine if the
media only wrote about
mayweather and logan yeah jake logan i
have no idea which one i'll be real with
imagine if the media wrote 7 000 stories
in two weeks about
just mayweather versus paul jake paul
we'd be like this is the stupidest thing
ever what was wrong with you right one
story we get it
if donald trump you know kicks a goat
and they write a story about it i'll be
like
you know he did that so he wrote a story
about it if they write 8 000 stories
over four months of like
donald trump incited insurrection the
insurrection oh the cops
yeah blame every single goat-related
injury on donald trump they're like
goats they're getting hurt more often
was this because trump kicked a goat
that's right big problem is a friend of
goat kicking when they're like he said
it
she said it he's bad she's bad that gets
that's the bottom feeding crap
but when you say like he said it this is
why it's good let me tell you for a
while about the ideas this is kind of
what you do with your youtube videos
or that's bad i'm to tell you why and
then you break down the ideas
you're acknowledging the crap but you're
talking about
the process which is what what i want to
say is i think it's perfectly legitimate
to talk about donald trump i think it's
perfectly legitimate to talk about
ocasio-cortez why they're prominent
figures influencing our country yeah
sure
but there are people who are like not
prominent but they're like
decently well-known activists that
become the center
like the target for like content and
it's like you can talk about it once or
twice if it's relevant
it's not it's not something you should
focus on so heavily and we should focus
on
the ideas around these things and what
they represent are you telling me to
stop making fun of ben shapiro is that
what i'm hearing no i just want you if i
stop doing ben shapiro
videos you gotta blame him
by all means make more videos mocking
you know okay
that's ridiculous everyone dude i dude
i'm so tired right now that i'm gonna
have some gaffes and joe biden's gonna
end up making cartoons making fun of me
he's gonna like i can't wait for that
this is
joe biden just starts roasting me he's
like look at this guy everyone's
laughing the whole country is just
roasting
me let me just say that video you did
recently
where it's joe biden's stutter in class
oh yes and joe biden that quote where he
says he used to walk around
oh yeah yeah please watch the video yeah
right guys
he actually said that this that that's
the best part about so
let's keep it family friendly but he
went around black neighborhoods
saying things just watch the videos yeah
just very
very offensive a crazy that's like how
can a political leader say that and
survive
like i feel like if i were which i never
would but like if i were to say that as
a joke like that's
you are cancelled young man he basically
was saying it on ironically he basically
went around telling he he claimed that
he went yeah black neighborhoods telling
black men
to wear condoms and that it's not
unmanly to do so and it's like well
first of all
like first of all joe you're catholic
you should know that like yes it is but
also
um could you imagine joe biden doing
that just like walking down the street i
didn't even think about that yeah joe
biden actually just going door-to-door
no not even like some like 40 year old
like you know black dude is leaving to
go to work he works the local bank or
whatever he's you know he's just got his
briefcase with him and then joe
is like hey hold on there man let me
tell you something my god it's got like
a bag of condoms
so embarrassing yeah check out we so
we've been doing a series of videos
where i will just take joe biden's
audio and string it together into a
conversation between him and someone
else
it usually comes out pretty funny if i
and i think i'm allowed to say that i
don't think i'm laughing at my own jokes
i'm just laughing like joe biden's a
good writer and he does good comedy and
i like to turn that into cartoons
sometimes so we just did
a cartoon about aliens visiting earth
and joe biden talking with them
you all should check that one out
excellent thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time